who leg cap show special guest my guy
corday is in here what are they doing
bro how you feeling man I'm very good
it's a little hot in this room I'm not
gonna lie it's cool a little toasty it's
fine uh well look man third album yes
sir
we didn't have to wait as long for this
one
um
12 months
yeah it's been a year now yep I feel
like I feel like uh it's been I remember
the the last album release party Dave
Chappelle was there yeah he hosted it
that was it that was pretty big no
that's a bar yeah he did a great favor
for me too I asked him and then he said
easy money yeah Steve Urkel was there
yeah he was actually yeah I was in a
joint circle with Simba Steve Urkel and
Dave Chappelle in back backstage at the
pepper was the peppermint Club yeah it
was the pepper yeah yeah a lot of good
people showed up the support killer Roy
showed up uh kids at work was there yeah
yeah like a lot of got a lot of love
from a lot of artists and people how
does the Dave Chappelle thing work out
like how do you guys become friends
first time you know what we got really
close during
um
the pandemic I will fly out to Ohio to
see when he was doing those shows yeah
exactly and um he's just a really good
it might be the Virgo connection too but
um
not that I'm like a more worshiper so
are you are you really into that I'm not
sure is that you're saying I'm not a
Moonwalker what do you worship God shout
out to God you know shout out to God the
one but uh which type of guy though
we're going Catholic God Christian God
baptism I'm a Baptist I'm a Christian
for sure okay but um
more so
um with Dave Chappelle like we just got
really cool because um somebody I can
always go to for advice and he just real
down to earth like he's just a real one
bro you know so visiting him in Ohio
like a town in kind of the middle of
nowhere it's in the middle of the time
the thing covered [__] paranoia yeah
it was it was awesome yeah so you guys
just from there just connected and it
was like Hey you know he's from Maryland
too so it's it's an easy thing
do you feel like because I feel like
Marilyn is low-key like highly slept on
when we talk about like kind of the
grand scheme of like hip-hop you know if
you got yourself you got guys like Wale
yeah logic yeah there's a lot of Hitters
from Maryland and bro Marvin Gaye's from
DC shout out to Marvel you know what I'm
saying we got such a rich culture of
music you know and DC Maryland Virginia
DMV United and stood as one it'll be so
much like because even Virginia got
Pusha got for real got Chris Brown Trey
Songz Fat Trel just got out fat Trail
hey shout out fat troll cold yeah I got
money I got power I got respect with
this I didn't say like growing up is
like a kid because like I said Trail
[__] boys huge fan like ain't no blow
on my projects like where the [__] is
the chick it felt like such a like
moment when he got MMG it felt like like
oh shit's about to go crazy yeah nah for
sure it was crazy bro like Trail Glizzy
Shy Glizzy yeah for sure
um like I said Trail huge influence Wale
obviously big flock so many local
artists too idk's killing it now IDK is
incredible so it's a lot of really good
artists out there area bro what right
now because I feel like you have great
taste in music and you're kind of like
you know you're not like uh you might
you might have some old head taste in
you for being a young kid but what are
you listening to I want to say I got oh
head taste I just think I like to go
back yeah but um
okay
Point may be proven I've been listening
to a lot of Al Green lately but I've
been listening to a lot of older music
for samples you know just to listen to
old head taste for sure yeah the silvers
you know what I'm saying just but for
sample purposes and it's because it's
[__] good like of course wine is
always going to be fine wine you can
always go back and watch Michael Jordan
highlights and they're still oh they're
amazing Pete Maravich no something not
so much you know what I'm saying yeah
once you get to like when the TVs were
black and white on YouTube the
highlights become really bad yeah
because you're like oh these guys would
be terrible today they couldn't last
because they were just playing against a
bunch of guys like look like me yeah and
I was like [__] is plumbing and then
okay yeah I got a game tonight right at
the National Basketball Association but
um
any hip-hop you're liking that is like
uh you know anything new like Have you
listened to new little yachty album no I
haven't yet I haven't yet crazy it's
it's dope yeah I got some trippy
psychedelic like yeah not I seen that it
was like an experimental album um shout
out to him for like it takes a lot of
nuts to do some [__] like that the type
of music you would love to listen to if
you're a shroom and hard yeah some good
shrooming music nah for sure yeah and I
gotta check it out I'll definitely check
it out what is your go-to shruman music
um
um let me see
to go to just anything Soulful anything
Soulful
um and it's also you can just type in
shroom playlist
yeah back to Marco Nirvana [__]
um yeah yeah well entertainment what
song is that um Entertainer it's a big
ass song and I'm crazy for not knowing
the time listening to Nirvana on troops
yes shout out to you yeah it's a it's
crazy
um Mac Miller is great on shrooms yeah
Travis is not Tame Impala yeah Tame
Impala of course that ASAP LSD LSD is
the one I feel like a head ass naming
all these like big shroom songs but
that's what I do I just go on yeah
and just hit play you're good yeah
you're super good worst trip you've ever
had
oh I've had a penny I've got a bad one
I've had just one bad one bro I was it
was it was just a dumb reason why I did
I was in a hall in the crib alone I just
shouldn't have did it I was in a dark
place in my life honestly shrooming at
home alone bro it was crazy it was
horrible pandemic no not pain so what
happened were you just like overthinking
everything freaking out yeah I was yeah
I was like really on panic mode like in
life like I was on like full-on panic
mode like it was crazy bro it was it was
not something I like the revisit it was
just it was a bad trip
explain to me what was going on with the
Abraham Lincoln fake fake beard thing
that was happening for that show because
I really legit thought because I hadn't
seen you online in a while and then you
pop back out and I'm like oh this guy's
just just saying like I don't know
what's happening here yeah it almost
this character I got big play day
um and I I was him in the r p video so I
was just like you know and I had to do a
TV show that day okay and I'm like you
know what and for the TV show I was big
play day my character that I my alter
it's kind of like my Alter Ego honestly
um and so for the TV show is called the
south side so I had to uh be my Alter
Ego big play day and I had my chops on
I'm like you know what bro [__] it I'm
gonna do the show with him and I didn't
think it was I was just like yo [__] it
like I thought it was real for sure
creative yeah that's crazy a [__] look
like Kareem Abdul-Jabbar is like Jesus
he's going straight 70s porn mode on
these mothers for real straight up baby
nights out here absolutely yeah
anyway you uh you go to a lot of
basketball games yeah I feel like you're
at front row of many I am you're very
passionate uh about the NBA and the
sport would you say I want to say that I
just
I'm in a blessed ass position in my life
to where I get courtside tickets for
free so for free for free how does that
work
uh my agent a manager and then sometimes
I know the players so quartzite for free
every time you've never paid not a
dollar wow right hand of God I've been
over a hundred in my first NBA game I
was Courtside wow well that's nice God
is great
what have you ever had like a situation
where you're talking [__] or like
somebody was like like you know you're
at Courtside you hear everything yeah so
you heard something maybe you shouldn't
heard no I don't talk now I don't talk
[__] at all because I like to I'm just
there to enjoy the game and I ain't
trying to fight no seven footer plus
you're I got hands are you a Wizards fan
yeah I'm a Wizards fan I mean that's
rough what are you gonna say we got
Bradley Beal like who cares for now yeah
you know for now when you stay there do
you want Bradley Bill to stay
there's no way you want him to stay as
uh Bradley Bill fan or a wizard fan a
wizard fan yeah I want Brad Bill to stay
why because he's like so you can
continue to fight for the night seed
you think we should just tank yes or
Victor win benign I think you guys trade
Bradley Bill kristaps porzingis kuzma
get a bunch of [__] picks and well we
gotta we got another thing what if we
just get another star then we we doing
something no one's going to DC I know
it's not gonna happen the closest thing
to another star you all got is that tall
awkward white man Chris stops porzingis
oh yeah
it's called the it you're getting a
distressed asset that's the best that's
the best case scenario for the Wizards
get a distressed asset like Chris stops
and he actually comes through and plays
all right what he's been doing we just
traded a hoochie um hoochie Rama
what rui hachimura
it's not huchirama nah that sounds like
a great porno speaking of BBC's hoochie
Rama baby hoochie in big uh like 70s
letters I'd watch a movie called hoochie
Roma baby that sounds like a great like
sitcom too hoochie Rama I think he's
gonna be good for the Lakers though
yeah he's uh I don't know man was he
good for y'all no he was straight he got
the job done he got the job done
shout out to him yeah you know he's got
his own pair of Jordans
he's got a like a rui hachimura version
of a Jordan six for real I think it's a
six yeah
hey shout out to hey hey young black man
getting money man can't be mad at that
you still doing Puma I see you got
Louise on what's going on absolutely I'm
wearing appointment but I had to match
the jacket so what happens do you get in
trouble if you wear Louis Vuitton shoes
nah because they're not a direct
competitor at Puma according to uh
article 11a section three of my contract
as long as I'm not wearing any
competitors is it frustrating that you
can't wear some fly Jays
it is until them quarterly checks come
in and I mean listen man Puma's on fire
man you know you know what's crazy
I might re-answer that
sometimes but Puma has a a wide variety
like the Puma Road collab is super and
I'm not on like this
fire [__] um yeah we got some [__] at
Point bro I ain't gonna lie we got some
good [__] no poop is great no they're
great and we're number two behind Nike
as far as his most athletic gear in most
sneakers so literally we're number two
behind Nike and we could and the dope
thing about Puma they're more like
inclusive like they'll get like a kid
super well they'll get like uh rude you
know what I'm saying they'll get like
like they work with who decides War like
all the brands that's really the ones
that's making [__] move and culture who
decides War
who decides War who
not the white from Atlantic the white
man his last name is man the white man
the white man
oh yeah shout out to Puma man shout out
to Puma so let me ask you something when
you like collaborate because a lot of
artists we see do these huge brand deals
yeah
um is there like
is there anything that like you're you
cause because I feel like you have a
very
like commercially viable image if I'm a
brand and I'm like I want to get
somebody who's young who's you know
tapped into the culture but won't you
know [__]
I don't know go on Instagram live at
three in the morning with an AK-47 and
threaten his Ops yeah
knowing that you're kind of that guy
I don't know if that's a compliment it
is okay thank you of course it is
I know I'm joking
um are you like super like mindful of
that when just moving around like
day-to-day life like yo like because you
I mean you said that uh you I mean what
songs did you drop last year we were
talking about was it Pepsi that broke
your Coca-Cola Coca-Cola so you're doing
[__] that like a lot of artists can't do
yeah you know what I mean getting
getting bags that a lot of artists can't
do so like when you're just thinking
about your social media or you're
thinking about just how you move around
in the public eye or stuff you might say
in interviews or social media are you
mindful of that
no not really bro because at the end of
the day the music is still the engine
that drives it off like you can be the
cleanest [__] but like if your
music ain't hitting then or if it's or
you're not connecting with the people
then that [__] that opportunity doesn't
exist so I just I just like to be myself
bro and I've never just been a
gunslinging ass [__] I own guns several
actually as you should with a license
you should protect yourself cute I got
endless guns you know what I'm saying
it's all super illegal but I say this
super illegal no super illegal I got
super illegal
Drake [__] I got dracos I got all type
of [__] legally you know what I'm saying
trick where do you live
Georgia Georgia Georgia okay you you got
it all then yeah yeah yeah yeah
if you're here no no no that's not
leaving you got a good lead yeah I gotta
send me all those all that [__] hey
that's good though let people know they
can't you know not I'm Joe I don't have
any semi are semiatos legal in the South
I can't I don't know he would know
because
fully automatics are illegal everywhere
correct
yeah I thought so yeah but yeah I got I
got hella [__] Bro in the South yeah I'm
[__] this guy right here was logged
into my YouTube channel on our our
company laptop besides the [__] up
porn history that popped up in my Google
internet yeah absolutely my YouTube
algorithm was just about machine guns
and handguns and I was like
what the [__] is going on it's because
this [__] Second Amendment ass
[__] over here searching how to
take apart handguns and [__] but you
know I digress but um you're strapped up
yeah yeah exactly but the point
um is that I just I I'm not never not
going to be myself bro for the sake of a
brand you know what I'm saying though
for the sake of but I turned down
millions and millions of dollars bro
because it's like it's a brand that's
kind of like off-brand for me as a
person because it's like I'm not trying
to just start selling ball Clippers you
know what I'm gonna ask you don't tell
me the company but tell me the genre of
bag you turn down is it an energy drink
is it ball Clippers no it wasn't ball
Clippers they didn't but but like what
give me like something that you've
turned down just the industry you don't
got to tell me what company it was
big I turned down huge features because
the artists I'm like yeah they like do
like 100 million monthly streams but I
just don't like the song and it might
not be the best business decision but
it's just like yo I'm still an artist at
the end of the day and I try to just
move with my heart and it sounds [__]
cliche and all this [__] but it's the
guys on it I try to just move with my
feeling you know but um so it's the same
with brain what about a brand what kind
of brand what's the brand deal you turn
down what's a brand deal with
wanted to come and have you bring back
Jewel House clothing he has a I'd rock
that for a couple of years
you remember Joe house Dwight DTLR all
over the country yeah
is it before Kanye I didn't I don't know
before it might have been like right
when he was here but it was a bad idea
yeah no no on the gaps yeah
yeah
he hit you right
no he's gone through some sort of you
know spiritual Reawakening he [__] up
you know he's trying to bring back easy
hey pray for yay man pray for yay
hypothetically he hits you chordae I
[__] up man I'm sorry I got to get
this easy [__] back popping would you
like to be the face of the new season
I might I'm gonna think about that Chef
yeah I'm gonna think about it I'm gonna
give it some serious consideration
absolutely okay I just got to see you
know what the designs look like but I
ain't gonna be like oh no because
everybody else is on some can't you know
I agree whatever I'm gonna definitely
consider it highly yeah I mean I think
and that's one of the forefathers you
know what I'm saying so he is he is one
of the forefathers in my opinion the
best discography in rap history
highly yes you I you can put a good ass
argument on that a good ass I think it's
it's
okay
hope but I think yay's got more class
like certified like undeniable Classics
but hoes up there but I also think okay
Outcast yeah for sure outcasts they
don't miss okay Kanye okay College
Dropout
late later station graduate graduation
all three Classics right away yeah all
three are Classics 808s classic because
it's just change music yeah yeah my
beautiful
um My Beautiful Dark Twisted Fantasy
that's five classic then we're going to
use this which in my opinion is I Think
Jesus
I think you're confusing I could be I
think you're not confusing I think
influential don't mean it's a classic no
I actually think he uses personally for
me I love so I don't sound too it's
crazy I don't think it's in uh consensus
hip-hop classic okay I think it's like
for me personally okay it's a classic I
got albums that I'm like it's a classic
to me but that don't mean it's a classic
to everybody you know no for sure but
going back to the original point just
because I'm trying to get my thought off
my bed if I cut you off of just like I'm
I can't be a slave to the brand bro I
say no to 95 of incoming brains and
feature everything bro it just got to be
like whether I do a song I Gotta like
really [__] with the song right or that
person no matter how big or small they
are you know what I'm saying if it's
like a brand it just got to be on brand
with who I am as a human being like Puma
do hella like community outreach [__]
they do hella charitable [__] they do
hella like give back stuff and I used to
wear Pumas in middle school because we
used to wear uniforms in a public school
and we had to wear all black sneakers so
I would have on the Pumas they're
affordable so I really [__] with Puma so
that's why Pumas I rock with Puma you
know what I'm saying I got plenty of
pumas in my closet that's it a lot more
Jordans but we're gonna change that for
court a thank you sir
I need a box some high-level
appointments is on the way for you high
level Pumas how's the high level thing
going it's going great we just need more
artists so how does that work for you
because you're obviously in full artist
mode yeah yeah you have a lot of
personal life developments happening
that are life-changing yeah do you have
time to even search for artists yeah it
just got to be the one that I've it's
all
it's all asleep at night if I turn down
a certain amount of bread or a brand or
a feature whatever if I know like I just
went with what my heart felt you know
what I'm saying or what I really love or
what moved me so it's kind of the same
with artists bro because I don't want to
just sign artists just to sign them I
want to just have the model like just
have a few artists and we really like
push behind them and I'm able to give
them the stuff that I've I've learned
even I'm still [__] I [__] up a lot
because like I'm a [__] up bro for sure
but I can't acknowledge that and I just
keep moving you know what I'm saying
that's my goal so um and just you know
with Ace and the whole team like pushing
behind them so just getting a couple of
artists you know because if you turn
down a deal that's nobody loses sleep
over that if you sign somebody and you
don't do Justice by them that's a human
being that's a human being that's um
when you sign the artist you're kind of
not even kind of you're responsible for
that person yo so you did a TED Talk
that was like the biggest Ted Talk of
the year yeah
was that very uh were you were you
nervous preparing for that because
that's a big deal to do it yeah bro I
was off that's one of them shroom nights
bro like when I had that bad I was like
[__] I got this Ted talk to do next week
that wasn't the man it was a uh [__]
it was a bunch of [__] Bro a bunch of
[__] it was a lot of [__] but um going
back to the TED Talk
I am
that was something I wanted to do
because I'm like yo it's just some cool
[__] and then when they actually reached
out like yeah we want coordinator to do
a techno oh [__] I didn't know right so
what was the question again talk about
preparing for that like you know that's
a big speech to write a lot I wrote a
speech and then I'll I sent it over to
Ted Talk and they had like certain notes
about it and I'm like bro like
I don't like what the f they sent me
like you know edit notes like this is
cool but this ain't and so I kind of
started panicking I'm like I just want
to write what I want to write and so I
just end up just doing that I just
ignored their notes and just deal with
it was the biggest one you know the
biggest one you're gonna do another one
no not no time so I gotta I gotta I
think I before I do another one I gotta
do some more [__] like some more
legendary stuff you know
hey we gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our folks at my bookie that's
right baby Super Bowl's coming well you
know in a month or so we got the
playoffs right now you could get those
future bets in on who you think out of
this uh barrage of teams that made it to
the playoffs is going to win the Super
Bowl you could bet player props we can
go NBA action on them so much ways to
make money with all the sports going on
and you could do it all at my bookie
right now if you go to my bookie and you
sign up for a new account use the promo
code bootleg and they will match your
first deposit up to a thousand dollars
you know what's dope about my bookie not
only can you bet on your favorite sports
but you could also get a little
Blackjack going little slot machines in
that thing give me a little loud little
roulette yeah me so much ways to get
paid on my bookie the most important
thing is though if you sign up
and you use the promo code bootleg at my
bookie go to my bookie my bookie my
bookie my bookie use the promo code
bootleg and they're gonna match your
first deposit up to one thousand dollars
right [__] now
listen I'm a degenerate but I'm pretty
good at this
I've been using my bookie for like 10
years all right very trusted they're the
best trust me they are the [__] best
wherever you're at if you're watching
this you can sign up for my bookie
account one more time that's my book you
use the promo code bootleg and they will
double your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars free [__] money
let's get to it all right boys back to
the interview
hey what UPS bootleg cab here to uh stop
the interview and tell you about
Bluetooth yes do you have a dick does
your husband have a dick
maybe does your boyfriend got a dick
does your wife have a dick who knows
um it could be harder I'll tell you that
yeah blue chill gets your dick real hard
to kick off that new year you know what
I'm saying if you want your dick harder
than
Advanced trigonometry senior year high
school then go to bluetooth.com right
now use the promo code bootleg and get
one month supply for free that's right
free all you got to do is pay five
dollars in shipping
they're going to deliver the blue chew
right to your [__] door and discreet
packaging all right same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable form
very discreet packaging mailed to your
house you don't have to go to a doctor's
appointment in person with anybody you
don't have to worry about embarrassing
conversations with strangers about your
[__] dick bro nobody wants to talk
about their dick with a stranger I take
that back I take that back
lots of people like to talk about their
dicks with strangers
if you're not that kind of guy or girl
or them all you gotta do is go to
Bluetooth right now and use the promo
code
bootleg and you're gonna get it sent
straight to your door that's right they
also got the new mint chewable that's
the same active ingredients as Levitra
so there's a lot of options to get your
dick right in the New Year it's 2023.
yeah your dick shouldn't be flaccid
after a like nice long stressful night
no your dick should be ready you don't
want to be a you know a victim of too
much stress too much anxiety and then
you look down and you can't stay hard
you imagine how [__] embarrassing
that is you get yourself a nice lovely
[__] young lady you bring her to the
place you're nervous she's a little
maybe she's a little out of your [__]
league and you start thinking too much
and that dick's not gonna perform it's
not it's not going to perform how you'd
like it to but you know how it will
perform if you're on that [__]
Bluetooth
you're gonna put in a [__] Luka
donkic 61 Point [__] performance on
that [__] all right so go to
bluetooth.com right now use that promo
code bootleg let's get back to the
interview for you what has been because
I think that the number one thing
artists have an issue with you mentioned
it earlier is somebody could get a tick
tock moment but it doesn't mean they
have fans yeah right you have done a
good job of like developing a fan base
thank you what is the hardest part about
like connecting with the people and
making them give a [__] about you
huh just going sound cliche but I think
it's just being yourself bro and not
just giving the [__] about like the
numbers you know what I'm saying like
even like with my last album I think
it's because I dropped at the top of the
year I did 24K first week everybody
reported at 20. I'm not going to Tweet
and be like no [__] I do 20 I did 24K
but whatever so I did 24K but I sold out
90 of a world tour and venues that's way
bigger than [__] that do triple
the numbers that I do right you get what
I'm saying so what's the point of doing
a 100K first week if you can't sell out
the novo you know what I'm saying or
certain venues that I'm doing me as a
with my little 24K and I'm doing triple
the venues and those people also aren't
turning down Million Dollar Deals nah
for sure on a 10 song conscious album by
the way you know what I'm saying so I
say this to say it's all about like what
connects you know just making music from
your heart that that relates to a
certain demographic or not even
demographic a certain Niche people who
or just whoever is for I'm I'm kind of
at the place right now I'm like yo bro I
just want to make music
it's trans with this new [__] I'm doing
bro I'm just more transparent than ever
ever
more vulnerable than ever more honest
than ever and whoever that connects to
is who's that was meant to connect to
and if it didn't connect to them I meant
and if that doesn't connect to whoever
then it's just not for you
production-wise who's on the new album
because you've we've seen you in the
studio with the who's who I want to say
you were in Madre and we didn't we
haven't heard what that sounds like yeah
we have it I mean so says that's like
the same story for like a million other
artists yeah everyone's like yo I was
there with Dre I'm like can we hear the
music hey I'm happy with my flick I'm
happy with you my mom got that [__]
framed in the car she should but who's
who's got beats on the album
um f and Z not sure if you ever heard of
them they're super cold
um ATL Jacob
um
my boy Ellie holler he's super tight
who else I can't think are you doing any
production oh Bongo Bongo super hard
T minus t minus
um nice little lineup yeah cool little
you know Avengers Squad what do we got
to do to get you in the studio with The
Alchemist oh I did [__] with Alchemist
we did I'm trying to Yo me and Alchemist
will make a fire ass collab you can't do
a whole album yeah I'm down for that all
the way
is that like because you're on a you're
on Atlantic Records yeah so like it's
probably a little bit more difficult for
you to be like I want to do a [__]
album with The Alchemist because no
because I'll just pay it myself hmm
that's fair not that he'll even I don't
even know what that'll be because my
argument I pay for the Beats what do you
I would love for you to do like a full
even if it's not an alchemist just like
one producer nah for sure I'm definitely
like that's one of my goals this year to
drop a couple of those like one from
Alchemist one with this artist but
Alchemist definitely at like The
Alchemist house with just me and that
producer
Metro would be super tight I don't
really I never met this [__] though
yeah
it's so good yeah so great that Thug
First free slime free thug I love the
transition he said every time we make it
rain it's a thunderstorm crazy yo the
transition from that record into the
future interlude afterwards yeah I'm
freaking I'm geeking that's just that's
that's that's not messing I listen to
that out more than any album Metro is a
culture curator he's amazing he's
awesome he's I think he's like I I was
thinking about this the other day right
because if we think about like I think
his new album is probably and this might
be recency biased but it feels like the
best hip-hop compilation I'm glad you
recency biased is the real thing it is
but I'm like when I'm listening to this
new Metro booming album I'm like I'm not
sure anyone has really ever done a
better compilation like Calvin's never
made an album better than that are we
going down the line whoever's got
compilation albums you know what I'm
saying I just feel like this Metro boom
and I'm he purposely like built it
around this cast of guys now he did that
he took Drake off of one one of the
songs who takes Jake off he did it for
the art it's [__] crazy yes we got to
get you a Metro Boomin in no that'd be
crazy [__] somebody who you worked with
um obviously he's in a tough situation
uh for a young thug
um that was on one of your kind of like
holdover
uh to eat just until EP yep me and Doug
got another joint and a can that I I
love a lot that I actually like more
than what's up but what's up just fit
that uh that
um that project a little bit better
because I needed some Tempo but um Thug
man real one bro he's always there
whenever I need like any advice you know
what I'm saying whenever I needed
anything bro he's just super genuine you
guys recorded those together yeah we
recorded both of them together what's
his process compared to yours like man I
gotta I can't write when I'm with him
because he does everything off the top
so I'm like [__] I got to do the same
[__] but even if I were to like write
some stuff he's patient he's with
whatever like with whatever but I try to
just keep up with him that's my goal to
just keep up at the pace he records but
still come up with some cold [__] right
I would say you've been with a lot of
artists who's got the fastest Pace
writing or recording Doug Doug yeah yeah
that's fair
who's on the new album besides we got
the new Anderson but you and Anderson
should do a new album together by the
way like yeah like like do like a 10
pack yeah that'd be crazy no it'll be
you know it's because I think our
chemistry on record is is so good
because he's really like one of my best
friends I don't have too many friends to
be honest he's a great guy he's one of
my best friends for real and so um so
Anderson's on the album who else
um I'm not quite sure yet and I don't
want to say a name just because I may
they might not make it or that song may
not make it in a grand scheme but I'll
let you know before it comes out we know
for sure you don't know one other for
sure no I don't I swear really bro you
you know the album coming out I don't
know
what's the name of the album
I don't know
just an idea
I'm sorry is it coming out and is it
coming out by the summer time yeah it
should okay and you don't have the
[__] name yet just tell me I'd rather
not say nah I'm dead ass you don't know
the name no I'm dead you could just look
at me and be like you know what bro I'd
rather not say all right
I don't know for sure I don't know for
sure that's my answer like I know the
name what I'm thinking of but it ain't I
don't want to sit here and promote a
name that ain't the name no more was
there a verse on this new album that you
know the name of a verse that song that
you felt like you might have got bodied
on a verse a verse I'm just now I'm
fishing for guest rapper verses do you
think there's somebody on your new album
that might have bodied you on the song
or came closer made you be like oh that
was close damn no no I like that
so what you're saying is everyone gave
you throw away verses on your own nah
[__] Ain't gonna do that [__]
it's not too many feet I literally got
like two features bro so you do know you
have features but they're not bro listen
you know I don't like to say the feature
into that paperwork I'm I'm kind of a
jinx hoe right like if we're both
walking and it's a pole we ain't
splitting that pole okay you know what
I'm saying if there's a crack on the
floor I ain't stepping on that I don't
step on crack you know what I'm saying
just smoke it it is as I say it's very
hard in L.A and I step on some sort of
crack somewhere it's everywhere oh it's
more fentanyl absolutely but um shout
out to that fetty WAP you know I mean
speaking of this shout out to fam [__]
that [__] crazy I wonder if fetty WAP
knew when he named himself that that
there would be a drug like named after
him like eight years later you know that
was like the most deadly [__] ever
that's like killing all half of the
country pretty crazy hey um obviously
very tragic let's switch speeds okay
very tragic situation happen if it
happened in Memphis
yeah the young man who got killed by the
five police officers uh you were very
much you got arrested protesting during
the pandemic after the George Floyd
thing uh which was awesome Brianna
Taylor purpose for Brianna Taylor but I
feel like that whole time
just the pandemic just is all mushed
together yeah and I think it was a
blessing in the sense of like it really
gave light to things that just always
are happening but because everybody was
just standing still and not doing
anything it's like no this is just
clearly super [__] up and it keeps
going on so I think it kind of helped
highlight and catapult the movement I
was going to ask you like
obviously
protesting is something that moves the
needle because it forces people to see
the ugly yeah
um two years removed from that what are
the things that you're kind of doing or
involved in that are you know kind of
that isn't necessarily on camera
um I think it's just one step at a time
right and it's just like whether it be
just donating to the right cause it's
talk trying to talk to the people who
are in power to try to get it done and I
can do a lot more you know it's still
everybody could yeah for sure it's well
I don't want to sit here and act like
I'm Marcus Garvey you know or whoever
the case may be but um
I think it's talking to the I don't know
I actually don't know the answers
honestly I just don't know but we can
it's obvious it's a [__] problem
it's obvious it's a big [__] problem
but I think it's the step is talking to
the people that's in position I think
the police bro
you know the original police were slave
Hunters
like actually like the original police
it's a real this ain't the same [__] I'm
just making up like the original police
so the infrastructure is just [__] up
because the same morals and values of
the original police officers was for
slave Hunters so now 200 however many
odd 1865.
so 200 plus years since slavery was
abolished even in a Reconstruction Era
like
sorry for the history lesson I also want
to make sure I'm saying the right
accurate as possible yeah so boom so I
said to say the original police were
slave Hunters so now
that [__] turned into this police
construct that we have now and a lot of
the same morals and principalities are
just embedded within the system so
that's why I think it's proportional
it's disproportionate yeah yeah it's
it's it's like if the system is broken
how do you tear it down and rebuild it
yeah you know what I mean yeah because
if you think about the Memphis thing
it's like it's a police thing like it's
like these cops are like they're they're
it's the it's the institution even no
matter what color you know I'm saying
black police is
just did something like that you know
what I'm saying so it's the institution
that they're a part of because the
origins of the institution comes
from racism 100 man
um so this new project uh because I feel
like album Number One you get the Grammy
nomination I actually liked your second
album more thank you um you know it's
because I thought you said personal and
I just thought it was
I thought it was more focused
I agree I agree it was more my second
album was more
from um
it was more polished like the lyricisms
is better no for songwriting was better
the the the construction of the album
like the sequencing of it was better I
think it didn't connect at the level
that I wanted to because it wasn't as
transparent and vulnerable that's just
my opinion so this album
we don't even know what's going to be on
the album yeah we don't know we ain't
including me you're gonna be on the
album I sure hope so that'd be such a
weird Flex obviously Metro boom like I
ain't even own my own album I got
everybody yeah that ain't it uh I need
my plug
like you said earlier you're pretty much
just like yo I'm doing what's true to me
at this moment and whoever it connects
to is who it's for absolutely do you
give a [__] though about because when
you come out the gate with a Grammy
nomination that's a pretty wild [__]
thing to do no for sure it's only like
eight of us who like debut like debut
album
yeah yeah that's got to be a gift and a
curse too because now you're looked at
in a certain light where it's like well
if you came first time got the Grammy
nomination what you're gonna do with
this next one yeah do you let that
pressure get to you or do you think
about it and let it psych you out at all
nah bro because I never I I was never
like the hottest [__] out when I first
came out it's always with me it's just
been like Luca Luca um
so it's been I don't know if there's a
weird noise but uh whatever I get it but
it's kind of just been steps at the step
but bro I've only been in the game
it'll be four years since my first album
five years since I like people started
to know my name and know my music and
[__] and um so five years since Kung Fu
came out it'll be five years in July
what year did I already see so I've
already seen so many artists just come
and go with this yeah small five it'll
be the artist that was the hottest and
I'm not saying no names because this
respect as long as they're able to feed
their families change their own family
lives it's love they still won they
still win this rap game is the lottery
so any level access you could you could
achieve [__] is better than 99.9 of
the rapper pool absolutely for sure so
um I said I don't have seen so many
artists come and go so I know for a fact
I'll be able to make music at the
highest level for the next 20 years and
still be able to make a great living for
the next 20 years off music I'm not
worried about that it's just about how
high am I gonna take you how high can I
take this [__] and every year I've been
leveling up and I've been able to see
this literally from my first tour I did
500 camera rooms my second tour did a
thousand cabins my last two I did two
thousand cap rooms you know and that's
where I kind of based my successful
first week these are real humans bro
that's a real fan because they had to
leave their house get a babysitter maybe
buy a ticket right [__] get dropped
off by their parents get dropped call
The Uber take a shower put on some fresh
[__] then wait in line and no matter
what the weather or not put on some
fresh [__] exactly or not showers to see
you do what you love you know what I'm
saying versus like a number that can be
skewed or falsified yeah a lot of these
[__] streams are fake
a lot of them I mean I would venture to
say
sorry Dwight
99.9 of these major label [__]
artists there's some sort of [__]
little tick on the [__] numbers going
on yeah I wouldn't doubt it bro and the
thing is
it's like I was saying like I don't it
don't bother me and I'm not just saying
that because some [__] does bother me
I'm a human [__] being bro I got
feelings and emotion but it doesn't
bother me with this because I'm seeing
real life wins when I'm doing a sold out
tour you know what I'm saying that's all
and that's the that's that's the real
[__] that matters so even when like
you're selling merch and you're you know
people are supporting you with their
where they're that's the [__] that
differentiates somebody who can catch a
record catch a moment and then somebody
who can have longevity and pay their
bills and you know and open up a club
and turn down million dollar deals from
The Gap absolutely never was a gap guy
myself I didn't I didn't even know that
it didn't even make it it didn't even
make it back to me you should yell at
him for that no that's cool I'd like to
know if the Gap was knocking yeah I
never knew that honestly
what's up you go tell them about the Gap
that never came across Montana really
never I didn't know but I say that to
say that's the stuff that don't even
come to me that you know what I'm saying
that's what I said it to say like I say
no to a lot of [__] bro I just like to
do what I'm passionate about what's on
brand for me as a human being and what I
love to do things I'm passionate about
things I love so it's cool bro also yo
how did I not make your top 10 list last
year bro it's cool which top 10 list top
10 rappers or top 10 albums
okay it's cool by the way I just I'm not
in my feelings about it I'm just asking
I mean I just didn't I didn't think you
had I mean it was a good year last year
I think you had a top 10 album last year
I think you had about a top 20. okay I
respect that you and on the rap and [__]
I just think the rapping list was tough
man
because there was a lot oh brother there
was a lot of rapping
this [__] Kev I didn't even know until
he told me he's like yo you know he told
me right before he walked in you know
you ain't can't make care of top ten
yeah it's football it's cool a lot of
people didn't make my top 10 lists that
are my friends Benny The Butcher didn't
make the top 10 list I think Conway you
might have snuck in I don't think he did
though I actually don't think he did
he might have
but there was a lot of rappers that did
not make the top 10 list I because I put
guys like my thing was last year like I
put a guy like Simba on the list because
Simba did the rapper [__] last year that
[__] hit every Outlet he had
moments on these [__] he like when I
saw Simba like
yo I'm trying to make sure y'all see me
as that [__] so I'm gonna go rap
everywhere
and he put out a cool project now
Simba's mad because I didn't put his
project in the top ten but it's on the
same thing hey it wasn't a top 10 album
love you you're on my top 10 hey I gotta
respect it bro yeah you okay what do you
think about this hey we got to stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family at hard Dean that's right
Hardin Las Vegas the craziest dispensary
in the world the number one dispensary
in the United States let alone in Las
Vegas all right maybe you're hitting
Vegas with your friends your girlfriends
whatever maybe it's a bachelor party
whatever's going on you're going to go
watch the Raiders suck [__] whatever it
is make sure you pull up to Hardy in Las
Vegas tell him I sent you they got the
craziest selection of Premium cannabis
I've ever seen in my [__] life the
pre-rolls the cartridges the Edibles the
flower all top notch all the best the
bud tenders are so friendly it smells
great it smells so good inside a Jardine
that they have their own Harding
signature scent candle
see I sniffed that and I just think of
Las Vegas and picking up some amazing
weed all right so go follow them right
now Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot
him a follow get all the details you
need you can get you some of this fly
ass Harding merch at hardinglasvegas.com
shout out to our family in Vegas I'm
excited too because coming up we're
going to be doing our very first podcast
from Jardin in Vegas with young gravy oh
yeah it's going down all right let's get
back to the interview hey we got to stop
the interview to tell you about our
family at Odd Socks that's right the
most comfortable socks in the
[__] world go to
oddsoxofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsocksofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [__] else is going on with their
Black Friday so and let me tell you they
got some new licenses we got to talk
about boys
particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist and shout
out to all you rappers and people who be
pouring your lean into this [__]
some Mountain Dew Baja Blast socks
Casino great [__] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [__]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[__] [__] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [__] ethica or
some [__] ass [__] Nike socks
[__] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview you think the average
music consumer
wants to be a Critic or likes or like
wants to be of of influence not like I I
think we're losing a pool of like people
that are just genuine music fans like me
bro I'm just a genuine music right I
remember this one artist dropped the
song and the fans were like
yo the song was good but this makes his
ass like what the [__] do you know about
a mix you know what I'm saying I think
it's too many like you can come I think
a lot of people like yourself right you
can comment on music because you've been
you've done the research you've been
doing this [__] for a long time you've
been around you've done the research the
history the knowledge
like a lot of these kids be putting out
hot takes and all of this [__] but not
with no information that's just social
media though yeah that's true so it's
just like everyone has opinion about
everything everything so it's not even
music it's like everyone thinks that
they're political experts yeah everybody
thinks that they're [__] Skip Bayless
or their [__] Sports these
[__] don't know [__] like I was
sitting
with some Phoenix Suns fans that I'm
related to in Arizona not too long ago
and with a straight face they try to
tell me that we made the right decision
to draft DeAndre Aiden over Luka donkic
and I'm like well you just don't watch
basketball and you're a [__] loser
and never talk to me about sports again
that was crazy see you at Christmas you
[__] what is that [__] DeAndre Aiden
doing now you know he's just getting
rebounds and you know not dunking
despite being seven feet tall I hope you
trade his [__] ass God bless him hey
black man get money I'm proud of you dog
me too let's I'd like to trade him for
another black man getting money
yeah I'm just saying top speaking of
being music critiques what's your top
five albums of all time of all time
it's just subjective
everything's subjective I know that's
cool your list not the list your list
um
top albums of all time yeah
Marvin Gaye was going on okay let's do
rap albums okay rewind go Okay so
rap albums top five
the blueprint yeah
it's one of my favorite albums of all
time okay regardless of genre so
I never change every day this is just
um so we got the blueprint
it
um
T.I urban legend oh
okay
that's the one that had the Manny fresh
many freshers he said he said I got a
Chevy he said he said I popped tags on
the throwback fast [__] please I'm
wearing these when I cut my grass crazy
I just this [__] was tight to me
um
It Was Written in eyes okay
no order obviously
affirmative action man affirmative
action yeah oh yeah
um
Kanye
College Dropout
that's four
then
future Dirty Sprite too oh PS2 it's a
very diverse fire yeah I had to bring
somebody from the track world you know
what I'm saying from all walks of life
that's the top five albums just just
that this came up that I just been
listening to recently yeah that Future
run
2014-2015 run it's kind of crazy when
you think about it 56 nights monster I
just [__] it's insane yeah nuts yeah
would you put future in your top 10 all
the time
I was just having this conversation like
recently with my boy um
of this generation of this all-time
record ever
um
it's tough it's tough bro top 10 is
tough yeah
tough he's definitely super legendary
all these little [__] today sound like
him everybody everybody sound like him
and Thug
super influential super legendary Super
Pop Culture got a classic album he does
yeah longevity yeah
reinvented himself
I think it's like seven to eight
categories right you got do they have a
classic album yeah longevity
quality of albums just overall
hit records
um
moments and influence how their peers
look at them
um
lyricism of course in bars lyricism bars
that the same thing yeah yeah okay
lyricism he could write the [__] [__]
out of a song a songwriting ability yeah
lyricism song I would say lyricism and
bars two separate counts yeah because
you can kind of put hooks on bars
songwriting yeah impact on pop culture
and influence fair you talked about
having a classic album I just went viral
on this podcast I was on because I said
uh that I did not think now this goes
back to the conversation we had yeah
that there's albums that are Classics to
me yeah and I do think each one of these
guys have those for me personally but in
terms of
how like consensus hip-hop Classics and
nobody can say [__] about but it's not
chronic get Richard I try and My
Beautiful Dark Twisted Fantasy good kid
math City I don't think Drake or J Cole
have a classic in that in that manner
I would disagree heavily so which one
we're gonna say take care in Forest
Hills Drive Right
I will go Forest Hills Drive for sure
classic album bro I think even amongst
like the like non-negotiable for sure
that's a classic album
Nothing Was the Same as a classic album
to me it is I think it's his best album
for sure man Tuscan Leather crazy
amazing
no just blaze me too right it is
I don't know I wouldn't know honestly
so that's a classic to me but I just
don't think everyone sees it that way
who's everyone though who is everyone I
mean if you were to take
a room full of [__] a hundred
[__] who are somehow you
respect their opinion about hip-hop I
don't think everyone would agree with it
I think everyone would say get rich or
die trying is a classic yeah I don't
think there you'd find a soul that'd be
like nah you're crazy
just to say it
so you think Nothing Was the Same as a
classic bro to me it is yeah take care
is a classic to me I actually like
other J Cole [__] more than Forest Hills
Drive
um I love cold man shout out to Cole
well shout out to you this new album
you're gonna drop it's gonna be a
classic
I got something y'all man I wanna I'm
not gonna say no [__] like that that's
up to the people to decide I have no
once I put it it's like once you put it
out there in the earth bro it's just for
[__] everybody else to consume and do
what they want album coming really soon
really soon no title
two wrapper features yep
Anderson pack that's the one what state
is one of the rapper features from
Chicago
so you and Dirk no let's see we ain't
gonna I said Chicago because there's so
many dope [__] from Chicago so you in
common no so you and G herbo listen it's
you and herbo it's him and Herbert all
right so look G herbo's on the album
it's coming soon appreciate you pulling
up for today yes sir I appreciate you
having me dog